are you gonna be watching uh this sunday
as the globes are on oh my gosh yeah
i already knew the answer was yes we're
gonna be obsessing you too kevin we love
this stuff right
oh i love it and i i mean i will be in
it i'll be deep in it i really will
kevin the golden globes is our mountain
and you are our fearless guide
so let's do this what can we expect from
this year
well the first thing you need to know is
that this will be the first year that
the golden globes will be hosted live on
both coasts
tina fey and amy poehler will host for a
fourth time tina will be in the rainbow
room in new york and amy will be
at the um beverly hilton in beverly
hills the historic home of the golden
globes and here's a cool thing
presenters will join them in person
so we will have some folks there but all
the nominees are watching from home just
like us they'll be watching and waiting
and
there will also be a limited in-person
audience made up of our front line and
essential workers
i love that very cool i love that so
much all right well now we got to talk
about the fashion though because
everyone tunes in for the red carpet we
want to see that
right but there's no red carpet this
year
okay oh my god brad pitt he's not so bad
remember this moment we all love this
but what is the what's the carpet going
to be like this year do they have other
plans kevin
to make sure that we don't miss out on
all this beauty and that glam the globes
has teamed up with instagram and hired
photographer
matt sales to take virtual portraits of
the nominee so that'll be cool
everything will be live on instagram
sunday night so at least you'll see
folks
dressed up and looking sexy because
that's what we're used to
instagram doing cohesive photographs of
the fashions with the same photographer
putting it on this platform chef's kiss
i love it
yeah remember remember how fun that used
to be sitting on the couch and watching
all the stars come down the red carpet
how many iconic
looks we have from the golden globe yeah
let's take a look actually
from some of the red carpet looks over
the years i mean
this is my favorite come on it's sunny
and sharp
that not perfection right there share i
love when people go for it don't be
afraid take a risk
lupita nuango in 2014 for 12 years a
slave i think that's when she
established that she has misses dropped
the mic fashion
lady gaga 2019 star is born yeah what
about member back in the
julia roberts in this that she won for
steel magnolias in 1990
wearing something that i think drew's
going to wear on the show next i was
going to say you know i love a tie
and here's angelina jolie in 2011 i
remember
that red carpet i remember i was
watching brad pitt and her pull up in
their car brad got out and walked
around and opened the door and let her
out i was like watching it myself like a
human being they were there and i was
like oh my god that's true
that was one of those moments where you
hold your breath by the way with
angelina it was one of those moments
where you're like
oh my god look at that i think that's
the definition of drop
dead gorgeous yes totes yeah oh timothy
chamberlain also
this is interesting when men can make a
real statement with that harmis
uh the heart that's a yeah that's a
harness that look was sick
and you want to talk about men making a
statement can we can we go talk about
billy porter jr in 2020
do you remember this yeah when he just
everybody was like whoa what
what award you after award show i always
look forward to what he's going to wear
he is now the the one to watch and can
we mention another one
drew at the globe in 1983.
what do you remember about that night
drew i remember
talking to lawrence olivier and dudley
moore
at the same time thinking this is going
to be the highlight
uh you know one of the great highlights
of my life and it still is it's a memory
i
always always take with me
i love that okay so e.t just published
their full
golden globes predictions list yep can
you give us your quick picks
for the big four categories let's see
best
drama why don't we start there what do
you think
best drama it looks like it's going to
be bank the most nominated film i think
there were snubs in this category we
should have seen the five bloods in this
category and also
i love michelle pfeiffer in french exit
i think that could have stuck in there
too but it'll be bank
all right what about best comedy or
musical who's gonna take that globe
this is gonna be interesting look
hamilton will win
hamilton should win hamilton deserves to
win
and i just think that performance still
captures our hearts but i mean look
are there some other things uh yeah but
hamilton will win
this is kind of what i love about the
new era is you would have to do almost
like a dramatic film that came out in
theaters
and to be eligible for nominations now
you can be
in the most important you know play one
of the most important plays
in history they can film it and now
you're eligible
the game is changing and i think it's
really opening up
avenues for people to get recognized
that otherwise were
not eligible and i think in keeping
with uh the new era is um
the three female nominees for director
and yeah this is a first uh there's only
been one
female uh to win a golden globe as
director it was barbra streisand in 1984
for yeah yeah i know
i know to do it funny enough and then
she was snubbed for an oscar nomination
that year
that's right and then she came as the
presenter
when the first female catherine bigelow
for the hurt
that's exactly right and it was also a
moment where lee daniels was nominated
and it was going to be a first for
either him or catherine bigelow
i would love to have seen lee daniels
get nominated as well for director
for the united states versus billie
holiday holiday yes
just incredible thanks it is fantastic i
think regina uh mcking will walk away
with the um
with the golden globe this year for one
night in miami
that does that does not take away from
anything these other women did but i
think that regina king it's her award to
lose
i i hear you and chloe zao and
fennel they have just
done what you know couldn't
get through before and i loved
when natalie portman who i just think of
as
a very strong person but also inherently
feminine
and just there's so many layers and
beautiful layers to natalie portman and
when she came in with that dress
with all the female nominees
tailored and sewn into the fabric i
remember that i think
people should voice what they are
looking for
um because it looks like people are
listening
and that is um very
very encouraging yep okay quickly what
about best tv drama
listen it's the hollywood foreign press
so the crown is gonna walk away with
this don't even think twice about it you
know mandalorian or other or the ozark
no the crown it was it was incredible
this year
but what about the best tv comedy who's
going to win that one by the way if
jillian anderson doesn't get it for her
margaret thatcher i won't be real mad
how great was her margaret thatcher um
for the comedy uh it'll be shit's creek
but listen let me say this
my heart is with ted lasso even though
shit's creek is gonna win
everybody loved ted lasso so much
everybody yeah is there anybody who
didn't like ted lasso no because it was
sweet and i think
yes especially during the pandemic
everybody was dying for a dose of that
goodness you know kevin
there's no one that ross and i would
rather be a tripod with
than you we love the fact that we get to
do this on
a regular basis thank you kevin we love
you so much
drew i always love hanging out with you
ross great seeing you and
congratulations ross
thank you so much thank you it's a big
week here
watch kevin every weeknight on
entertainment tonight
you